[Música]
vamos ahora las noticias de salud y para
ello me acompañan Natalia plazas Natalia
Buen día para usted Buenos días Ángela
vamos a hablar sobre la hemofilia hoy 17
de abril y que no es un día cualquiera
es cuando se conmemora la lucha contra
esta enfermedad sí Ángela hoy recordemos
en este día especial que la hemofilia es
una dolencia hereditaria y las personas
que la tienen suelen tener hemorragias
constantemente debido a que les falta la
proteína que hace que la sangre coagule
para entender un poco más sobre este
tema nos acompaña el Doctor Carlos
Eduardo Pérez médico infectólogo de la
Universidad Nacional de Colombia y
asesor científico de France 24 para
iniciar doctor podría explicarnos un
poco más sobre la hemofilia sobre Qué es
la hemofilia y cuáles son las dolencias
de las personas que la padecen
recordemos que la hemofilia es una
enfermedad que casi exclusivamente está
en la población masculina son los
hombres los que somos afectados por esta
enfermedad Y de qué se trata la
enfermedad la enfermedad es que los
factores de coagulación que son las
proteínas que se encargan de que no
sangremos de que se hagan trombos que se
hagan los coágulos no están ausentes en
estas personas y al estar ausentes
Simplemente no hay esa coagulación y la
persona sangra muy fácilmente La
hemofilia es una enfermedad que es
portadora las mujeres y enfermos los
hombres y por eso ese esa transmisión
ligada al cromosoma X lo que hace
característico de que sean los hombres
preferentemente los que enfermos de esto
en una condición genética y que no se
coagule la sangre cuando hay un trauma
cuando hay un incidente o en cualquier
momento de la vida del ser humano
doctor Buen día para usted A cuánto
porcentaje de la población mundial
afecta esta dolencia y bueno está el
mundo con plena conciencia de las
necesidades de estos ciudadanos
Ángela uno de cada cinco mil recién
nacidos puede padecer hemofilia este día
lo que nos hace sensibilizarnos a que
esta es una enfermedad que primero se
puede prevenir a través de una
consejería genética pero también se
puede reconocer fácilmente en la
infancia cuando hay sangrados
espontáneos tomando una muestra de
sangre con traumas mínimos y alertar el
grupo médico y a los grupos familiares
para que se busque la ayuda y ya que
esta es una enfermedad que cada vez es
mejor controlada a través de las
medicinas que tenemos actualmente
Entonces en este día reconocemos digamos
una enfermedad de una prevalencia
importante uno de cinco mil pero que si
se hace reconocimiento temprano se
puedan ser intervenciones terapéuticas
tempranas también doctora las ongs que
impulsan esta jornada contra la
hemofilia llaman a que este día
concretamente en 2023
ya van a ser el lema de esta jornada la
que la prevención de las hemorragias sea
la Norma atención para las personas que
la sufren que hace falta para hacer de
este lema un estándar internacional
claro Es importante saber que muchas
veces los pacientes llegan a los médicos
Ya con procesos de hemorragia entonces
de lo que se trata en este día es de Qué
elementos se utilizan farmacológicos
para prevenir las hemorragias lo primero
es el diagnóstico hacer la
sensibilización temprana de que cuando
una persona tenga un trastorno
hemorrágico se sospecha la hemofilia lo
segundo que se caracteriza Qué tipo de
mofilidad hace esa o b y lo tercero que
a estas familias a esas personas tengan
acceso a la salud para prevenir que los
fenómenos hemorráicos no sucedan si no
hay hemorragias no hay trastornos
funcionales no hay otro tipo de
trastorno no hay peligro de muerte y se
puede controlar la enfermedad entonces
es una digamos un día muy importante
porque es cómo hacemos la intervención
terapéutica temprana para que no haya
hemorragias y no hayan consecuencias de
esas hemorragias en estos pacientes
Bueno en ese sentido doctor Sería bueno
que cerráramos hablando de las terapias
que existen actualmente para tratar la
hemofilia y los avances que ha tenido la
ciencia para los pacientes que tienen
problemas de coagulación usted nos
cuenta
ha sido increíble lo que ha pasado en
los últimos años hace 20 o 30 años se
utilizaban derivados sanguíneos es decir
donadores que se extraía de la sangre y
se le colocaba a los pacientes esos
tenían los problemas de que podía
producir infecciones derivadas de las
transfusiones sanguíneas hoy tenemos
anticuerpos sintéticos tenemos una otras
alternativas terapéuticas que son
muchísimo más seguras que no tienen
riesgo de seguridad de transfusiones
sino Son elementos sintéticos y por eso
no tiene ese riesgo controlan muy bien
la enfermedad y se interviene
tempranamente previenen las hemorragias
sobre todo articulares que pueden
terminar dañando Y afectando
funcionalmente estos pacientes y vienen
nuevas terapias además de la consejería
genética que pueden intervenir para que
la enfermedad digamos tenga una
condición de cronicidad pero que no
tengan ninguna repercusión en la
funcionalidad del individuo es decir que
hay tenemos alternativas tenemos
tratamiento necesitamos acceso salud
sensibilizaciones diagnóstico y sobre
todo Buscar a las personas que son los
hematólogos que son las personas
encargadas de manejar para que se pueda
surtir estos tratamientos a este grupo
de población doctor sea como como
mencionaba son bastantes los avances que
se han conseguido en la ciencia en
materia de hemofilia Sin embargo la
federación Mundial de la hemofilia y
otras entidades llaman en este día a una
mayor investigación una mayor inversión
en investigación sobre esta dolencia
Cuáles cree usted Cuáles considera que
son las prioridades en la lucha contra
esta enfermedad
Natalia pues tenemos primero que hacer
esa intervención sobre la consejería
genética segundo la intervención sobre
la terapia génica que podría arreglar
esa mutación que hay en este grupo de
pacientes para que los anticuerpos
Perdón para que los factores de
coagulación se produzcan naturalmente y
obviamente desarrollar otras estrategias
mucho más económicas para suplementar
los factores de coagulación que están
afectados sin embargo digamos que lo
importante es que reconozcamos la
enfermedad que estas personas la inmensa
mayoría hombres tengan acceso a
servicios de salud y que la ciencia siga
avanzando para poder controlar la
enfermedad y que no haya hemorragias en
estos pacientes que es el pedido que
hacemos constantemente no solo para esta
sino para otras enfermedades Gracias
doctor Natalia a usted también Muchas
gracias muchas gracias Ángela